yes the question is what is the greatest
security issue in this asian and i like
to see that the nuclear issue in the
forum at korean peninsula is the big
decision and i would like to see that
approach to solve his problem is by
diplomatic way peacefully groups SI i
would suggest that all countries in this
area but the believers are also have
influenced to try to come be the
solution of this issue is to approach in
the peaceful way not to put pressure on
Lorien particularly could sanction power
political section economic sanction or
even by put the military develop
military part don't do this way but try
to come with this will make you see
discussion and that's all countries s i
understand that there is a six-party
talks let's have this box life and make
useful of this negotiation and come to
talk with peacefully